une sculpture un vestige le capitalo est
en fait un fauteuil créé en 1971 par
studio 65 un collectif avant gardiste
italien au musée de la ville les sièges
font leur révolution et remonte le temps
pour les années 60 70
dans les années qui suivent
immédiatement la guerre dans les années
50 et au début des années 60 on reste
encore sur un fauteuil relativement
traditionnelles et à partir du milieu
des années 60 la designer remettre en
cause ce design dit fonctionnaliste de
la prière pour libérer les formes pour
libérer qui accompagne cette libération
des moeurs et donc le fauteuil perd
effectivement toute référence avec ce
qui peut ressembler à un fauteuil et des
créations 100 pieds sans dossier pour
une confrontation france italie
le musée de la ville a rassemblé ses
sièges issus de sa propre collection ou
entrer une dizaine d'années de design
présenté par catégorie c'est aussi une
période de révolution technologique
parce que cette révolution qu'on observe
dans le fauteuil est permise par une
raie ou une révolution des tulipes de la
technique les années 60 par exemple
marque l'émergence des mousses des pvc
dont des matériaux qui permettent
justement des fauteuils ou le
polyuréthane des matériaux qui
permettent donc vous fauteuil de gagner
en légèreté que de gagner en confort en
élasticité
l exposition est en visite libre depuis
le 5 février les équipes du musée
propose aussi des visites guidées
la prochaine a lieu le samedi 29 février
une visite comme si vous étiez dans un
fauteuil